my name is uh sean fraser good uh good
afternoon everyone uh marshall tulimand
i'm the member of parliament for central
nova which happens to include the
halifax stanfield international airport
and i'm also uh here today in my
capacity as canada's minister of
immigration refugees and citizenship uh
before i get too far
i want to give a special thanks to our
guests from air canada and the shapiro
foundation uh for uh for being here
today and for uh their role in an
integral partnership that will uh share
news uh of with you uh shortly i also
want to give a huge thank you to our
hosts here at the uh the airport it's
nice to have the occasion to come by
again
after a previous uh an important
announcement for the airport uh but this
is as much about uh the importance that
the airport can give back to us uh as a
community and i'm very grateful uh not
just for hosting us here today but for
the work that you do in nova scotia and
for canada it's it's so greatly
appreciated uh of course my colleagues
uh darren fischer jaime batiste and lina
melech diab uh so great to see all of
you here today uh thank you for joining
uh for uh for an announcement that i
know is very important to all of you
given our conversations uh about the
need to continue to do more to support
ukrainians who are uh fleeing this uh
unjust uh and unnecessary war of
aggression um
very pleased to be here with uh all of
you uh i want to give the special thank
you to uh sarah it's just sarah wiseman
who i knew growing up as sarah mcintosh
who's the canada director of the shapiro
foundation and david rio vice president
government community relations with air
canada thank you for both of you to
being here today
um look it's been now
more than a month and a half that we've
been witnessing
the horrific acts of violence conducted
by putin's regime
with this latest invasion into ukraine
i can't help but think the values that
have helped deliver peace and prosperity
to canada for my entire life and in fact
going back uh 80 years now since the end
of the second world war
those values that underpin the
international legal order that we
know today uh include
the respective territorial to uphold the
right of peoples to self-determination
the very notion that a person should
have a say and who makes decision that
impact the quality of life that they get
to enjoy
those values are all under attack
with this war of aggression that's been
launched by vladimir putin and it's very
important to me that canada does its
part to uphold these values when they're
under attack not just
at home uh but on the territory of one
of our sovereign allies in this case
ukraine
dozens of uh communities and cities uh
of all sizes have been destroyed uh
ukrainians have mounted an
incredibly brave defense of their
homeland
and that incredible defiance and fight
for sovereignty sovereignty continues
and i want to communicate
to ukrainian canadians who may be paying
attention that canada will be there with
you every step of the way
the canada continent
is
we're going to do everything we can to
make sure that ukrainians are supported
over the course of their stay in canada
uh once they arrive
now there's been another number of
measures that we've put in place uh
today we started planning for the
potential influx of ukrainians who would
be seeking safe haven in canada uh on
january 19th when we established an
internal task force to ircc
we began by deploying uh certain
elements of an operational readiness
effort whether it was putting biometric
kits or or human resources in key
locations to the west of ukraine for
those who may be fleeing to have
expedited access to immigration
officials we extended measures that
allowed people who were already
ukrainians i should say who were already
in canada on a temporary basis to extend
their stay and made them eligible for
work permits or study permits as the
case may be
for people who already had an
application uh in the inventory of of
cases uh within our department we
started prioritizing them on an
expedited basis
but we also knew we had to do more to
get people here more quickly who would
be fleeing this uh horrifying war
that's why we launched
in mid-march the canada ukraine
authorization for emergency travel this
is an expedited pathway for ukrainians
who are fleeing this war to come to
canada what we did was built a new and
innovative system around the existing
visitor regime because we knew it had
the capacity to process large numbers of
people to that would allow us to respond
in real time to a conflict
where
there was a unique and distinguishing
feature in that
after it's safe to return home those
seeking temporary protection
would want to do so
with the advent of this new emergency
program
we've now seen
that the is is holding up very well uh
i'm pleased to share that although it
launched march 17th it had a two-week
processing period to get people approved
to come to canada uh which means we've
only uh been processing people for
approvals over the last three weeks or
so
and already there are now more than 54
000 ukrainians who have been approved to
come to canada under this particular
program
this expedited pathway to canada for
ukrainians will provide three-year stays
for those who need it and newcomers will
benefit from access to a work permit in
hand
on arrival should they wish to apply for
one
their children are going to be able to
go to school and immediately have access
to work and study opportunities and even
though most ukrainians are arriving as
temporary residents we announced
recently that we would be expanding
settlement support that's typically
reserved for permanent residents to
ukrainians who are fleeing this war in
recognition of the special circumstances
that make them particularly vulnerable
this means that ukrainians who are
coming to canada are going to have
access to key services to help them
settle into their communities this will
include things like language training
information about life in their new
community information about how to
search for a job or to sign up for a
bank account or in some instances
simple things about knowing how to
enroll your child in soccer or to ride
the bus if you have public transit in
your community
canada
additionally a couple of weeks ago the
prime minister co-hosted the stand up
for ukraine event uh alongside the
president of the european union and he
announced additional supports for
ukrainians who were fleeing this illegal
war launched by vladimir putin those
arriving under the canada ukraine
authorization for emergency travel will
include what will benefit from new
supports including six weeks of income
supports
including two weeks of stay in hotel
accommodations and to make sure that
there these benefits are in place to
make sure that they can get off on the
right foot once they arrive
we've also established a partnership
with the red cross to provide reception
services to ukrainians as they arrive
this includes on-site first aid at the
airport where individuals and families
first arrive
it includes people who have particular
mental health expertise it includes
people who have information about the
local job market information on how to
apply for a social insurance number
we've put these measures in place to
make sure that we don't just make it now
over the past few months
i've heard time and time again from
canadians that they want to help
ukrainians in any way that they can
because they believe that the
circumstances they're facing are unjust
without a second thought communities
have already done so much to welcome
those fleeing putin's war people are
offering their homes their food their
time their energy this is who we are as
canadians and it's part of a long and
proud tradition that we've established
of helping those in need
and while we as a government continue to
do everything we can to support
ukrainians before and after they arrive
in canada there's been an immense
showing of good will from canadians
across the country who simply want to do
their part to contribute to something
they believe is the right thing
and by tapping into this goodwill we can
establish partnerships that build on the
supports that i've already shared
details of for ukrainians who arrive in
canada i do want to say that we have
made a decision that the prime minister
announced a few weeks ago
to launch certain chartered flights
for ukrainians who are seeking to come
to canada but there's a really unique
factor with respect to this crisis that
communicated to us uh that charter
flights would not be the only solution
we realize in a typical uh refugee uh
resettlement initiative that we have
large populations of people who are
concentrated in certain areas in some
instances it's literally people who are
in a refugee camp i can think of the
syrian effort with those who've come to
canada through jordan or lebanon for
example
where people were being managed through
a centrally run
refugee resettlement initiative by the
unhcr
where people had access to an airstrip
and were waiting for an airplane to
arrive to cart them back to
their country of destination in our case
of course canada there's something
unique with the ukrainian crisis those
who fled uh westerly have not been in
refugee camps for several years they're
moving through europe fairly freely and
stopping wherever they can first find a
safe place to rest their head
while this may be a positive thing
from a human protection point of view it
makes the logistics of having people
come to canada that much more
challenging when you talk about
chartered flights
the solution will involve a mix of
chartered and commercial flights and
today our guests are going to be sharing
details about a new ukraine to canada
travel fund an initiative with miles for
migrants the shapiro foundation and air
canada that's going to help many many
ukrainians find safe even here
joduin
voyage ukrainian is
an initiative
miles for migrants the foundation
shapiro air canada
ukraine
canada
before i pass it over to david and sarah
to share details who will speak more
about this extraordinary initiative i
want to take the opportunity to launch a
call for action with the canadian
business community who i've been hearing
so much generosity from from ngos who
are seeking to do more to support
ukrainians to provinces and territories
who continue to step up in the spirit of
the team canada approach that i've seen
regardless of partisan affiliation
regardless of which level of government
and i want to call on everyday canadians
to continue to find innovative ways to
support ukrainians in their own
community we need to keep bringing
people together by encouraging
partnerships across all parts of our
society and to find ways to continue to
do what canada does better than any
other country in the world
that's helping the most vulnerable in
any way that we can
with that i'm so happy to pass it over
to david to share some important details
about this exciting initiative thank you
so much merci to demonstrate
thank you
mr melanie
wiseman
[Music]
on behalf of our canada
our country's national global airline
i'm very pleased to be here today
together with our 30 000 employees we're
humble to support ukrainian to travel to
canada
and announcing that we're going to make
a narrow plan donation of 100 million
points
this donation will give the flexibility
of travel on the star alliance global
network which include travel not only on
their canada but on our partner carriers
lufthansa lot polish airlines swiss
united airlines and other carriers
therefore providing a wide range of
efficient travel options
we're also pleased to work with the chef
euro foundation who'll be matching
additional error point contribution and
to continue collaborating with miles for
migrant one of our long-standing
charitable partner
all of this collective effort
contributes toward the kenyan government
goal to enable thousands of ukrainians
to travel to canada
no contributions
swiss united airlines
canada is really committed to continue
collaborating with partners and other
stakeholders to help
canada
mercy thank you
[Applause]
thank you minister fraser and david and
good afternoon everyone
the shapiro foundation is a boston-based
philanthropic organ
excuse me boston-based family foundation
whose philanthropic efforts are focused
exclusively on initiatives that benefit
refugees and displaced persons around
the world
on behalf of the shapiro foundation's
trustees ed and barbara shapiro i want
to share that we are honored to be here
today standing in partnership with the
government of canada miles for migrants
and air canada
we recognize that there are many
ukrainians and their families facing
unimaginable circumstances
who want to travel to canada but who
have limited means to pay for airfare
we also recognize that there are many
many canadians across the country who
are looking for ways to help
so we are issuing an invitation to
canadians to donate to this collective
effort to bring uk ukrainians to canada
on no-cost flights
the shapiro foundation and its partners
share the optimistic goal of seeing at
least 10 000 ukrainians and their family
members access these no cost flights
there are three ways that canadians can
contribute to this program
they can donate aeroplan points directly
through air canada
they can donate other airline loyalty
points directly through our partner
miles for migrants
or monetary donations which will be used
towards flight purchases can be made
made through the jewish foundation of
greater toronto
as an added incentive to help us reach
our goal
the shapiro foundation will match
donations by canadians up to the
equivalent of a further 50 million aero
plan points
the shapiro foundation recently
undertook a similar partnership with
miles for migrants in the united states
and that resulted in a donation of more
than twenty thousand flights for afghans
going to the u.s
we're excited to see what canadians step
forward to do
canada has long been recognized as a
global leader in efforts to create
opportunities for displaced individuals
at the shapiro foundation we recognize
that canada's reputation as a leader in
this space is due in no small part to
the generosity of canadians who always
step forward to welcome the stranger in
need
whether in a personal capacity or as
part of a corporate initiative we invite
canadians to join us
in this effort to facilitate the welcome
of ukrainians in need of a safe place to
call home here in canada thank you
[Applause]
folks let me just say on behalf of the
government of canada how grateful uh we
are for your generosity uh the combined
impact of this um
this astounding donation is going to see
at least 10 000 ukrainians
receive free transportation to canada
after they've qualified for entry
through our our special program um this
is the kind of generosity that
demonstrates that out of a crisis you
can sometimes see the very best that
humanity has to offer
to see
air canada and the shapiro foundation
step up in this way
is something i will remain grateful for
for a very long time
um that concludes the formal set of
remarks of course we'd be happy to stay
and receive whatever questions uh those
who are with us from the media may have
uh thank you so much
so thank you everyone merci to loans uh
i'm natalie pourier uh ircc
communications advisor natalie polly co
i will be moderating the questions and
answer period today
we will have questions from the room as
well as on the phone
and we will start with questions in the
room
i will ask that you speak in this mic
when you do ask questions from the room
introduce yourself before you ask the
question and to who your question is
asked to
and then you will have a follow up
question if you would like
the person
uh
see
so we will start the question period now
who anybody in this room have a question
in question
hi my name is pat healy from the laker
news this question is for minister
frazier
what is the update but the health and
education funding for folks arriving
from ukraine there are a couple families
in these hands who have ukrainian
refugees arriving and they have been
told that they're going to have to pay
for the education and health themselves
will the government of canada be helping
to cover any of these expenses
uh thanks very much uh pat for the
question and i i appreciate it this is
one of the things that we've been
working on with
our provincial and territorial partners
from the very beginning
so the federal government's piece that
we we've made
agreements to cover already uh include
six weeks of income support and include
two weeks of temporary hotel stay
include access to certain charters of
course this private donation coming
today is supplementary to that
we've also extended settlement supports
that include
the kind of measures i outlined in my
remarks and the partnership of the red
cross
when we've been having conversations
with our provincial and territorial
partners our large focus is
what can we do to have those other
levels of government extend health and
education services the conversations
without exception have been going very
very well not necessarily every province
has nailed down their their approach to
date but we have seen quite a few
provincial and territorial entities step
up and say yes these services will be
covered we're going to continue to work
with a national table we've set up to
have
regular weekly conversations with
provincial and territorial partners with
settlement sector and with the federal
government to figure out what we can do
to ensure that everyone who arrives has
access to these services
so with respect to the very specific
situation on health and education
services for those arriving in nova
scotia we still have to have continued
conversations with the provincial
government here but i'm sure that they
would be happy to
respond to those specific questions on
those two areas of provincial authority
do you have a follow-up question yes i
do
what does it mean to see the support
here today
with this uh you know announcement
um you know i feel um
i really appreciate that question i feel
very lucky um i feel very lucky to be
canadian
i've seen over the course of um
uh my time in in this position since uh
october of last year but more uh notably
just uh being in the uh the throes of of
planning for this humanitarian crisis as
it emerged um and what astounds me more
than anything else is how welcoming and
supportive canadians are how welcoming
and supportive nova scotians are
and the donation uh that we see today is
is extraordinary not just in the
magnitude of its generosity
but in how well it reflects the uh
experience i've had in speaking with
canadians who want to help
um
you know one of my predecessors in this
position used to joke that uh he's
unique amongst uh immigration ministers
in the developed world and that his
biggest problem was that he can't
welcome enough newcomers can't bring
refugees here quickly enough um
similarly one of the greatest challenges
that i face uh is coordinating the
extent of the goodwill that we're seeing
coming from the canadian business
community from different levels of
government and from canadian households
so
what do i feel in response to uh to this
generous donation that we've learned
about today
extraordinary gratitude it has inspired
me a sense of pride
not in my role as minister of
immigration
but in my role as a canadian who cares
deeply about doing the right thing for
vulnerable people and
and if i could just reiterate my
gratitude to air canada and the shapiro
foundation for this extraordinary
gesture today
it represents to me something that is
both extraordinary but stereotypically
canadian at the same time and i'm very
proud to be a part of it
thank you
we will now go to the phone lines uh so
if the operator can
put the next media on the line of
magnali or ling telephonic
if we
say
the one that you mentioned earlier in
your opening remarks that allowed a
three-year
stay
for for ukrainians but you also
announced that you work on a
um make a new stream uh in terms of a
family
reunification so what's going on on that
field uh why is it taking so long to
announce something on
their family reunification plant
sure i um i think you think the volume
cut out at the beginning i assume that
that question was was for me um uh so as
i understood it just to make sure uh uh
i captured the whole thing is is uh
why uh what's the status update on the
family reunification piece so if i fail
to answer it i'll count on you to come
back because i did miss just the first
few seconds of your question
um so we made a commitment to do a
couple of things when we launched this
new immigration pathway
one of them was to expedite applications
that were already in the queue which
we've been doing to
a significant success
oh thank you very much uh the second was
to create this new expedited pathway uh
which has now approved more than 54 000
people and and the third
was to launch a new family sponsorship
initiative um one of the reasons that
it's taking a little bit longer to
design the family sponsorship initiative
and we do expect to have more details i
don't have a specific date for you but
um uh probably within a matter of of
weeks maybe a little longer but uh and i
apologize for the ambiguity but uh the
the reason why it takes a little bit
longer is our focus right now is to
provide a safe haven to people who are
seeking uh refuge who've uh fled this
this war
the people who get here on a temporary
basis will still be eligible to apply
for
this family sponsorship initiative
which would grant them permanent
residency
the urgency with which a person needs to
become a permanent resident is not quite
the same as the urgency with which a
person needs to
flee a war zone when they may have lost
everything and don't have a safe place
to rest their head for a night
we're going to continue to engage with
the
ukrainian canadian community to make
sure that we design the program with the
full benefit of
the needs that the community is
communicating to us
but we do want to make sure that we
maintain the priority response to those
who need a safe place now
and provide a long-term and permanent
opportunity for resettlement
once the
the dust settles on on having the
program in place that will safely allow
people to
come to canada as part of this
humanitarian initiative
okay and um as a follow-up
okay um
if i have a follow-up minister i don't
know if you can hear me at all um but um
okay good um so um
you mentioned in your opening remarks
that chartered flights are not the uh
the only solution in that case but what
is currently being done
uh in regards to chartered flights
and
in regards to the
members of the
the canadian armed force that that were
sent in in poland how are they able now
to help
refugees ukrainian refugees
so there was a couple different aspects
to your question one was a status update
on what's happening with chartered
flights the other is the role of the
canadian armed forces personnel who've
been deployed to poland to help
facilitate the
exit of ukrainian refugees from ukraine
ultimately for onward settlement toward
canada
on your first question with respect to
chartered flights
we've made the commitment to launch
chartered flights but we need to make
sure that we're deploying our resources
in the most effective and efficient way
one of the unique nuances that's present
in this crisis that is
unique compared to other humanitarian
crises that we've addressed in recent
years
is the fact that people have spread out
before and after they've been approved
to come to canada under the new canada
ukraine authorization for emergency
travel
this means that a person who may have
fled ukraine applied for
this expedited travel document in warsaw
may now find themselves in in paris or
berlin and in fact some people have made
their way to uh to berlin before
applying to come through this program
and berlin is actually the second
busiest visa application center we have
when it comes to the applications to
take part in this program um that lack
of predictability and migration flows
means that it's more difficult to
arrange
for chartered flights to pick people up
from a particular location for onward
travel to canada
what we've been doing to help manage
that is about a week and a half ago
we launched a survey to solicit
information from everyone who's been
approved to come to canada under this
new expedited travel document
the survey asked questions about where
the people are now their anticipated
travel dates whether they still intend
to come to canada and where they want to
go
we should have the first tranche of
information as a result of that survey
any day now and once we have a better
understanding of where people are when
they want to travel where they want to
go it will allow us to plan the
logistics of charter flights more
effectively
of course having the benefit of this new
program announced today i will no doubt
change the travel plans for many
individuals in terms of whether they
would wait for a government charter or
take a commercial option which may be
more effective as a solution for certain
individuals who may not be in the same
location where we see large numbers of
people who've been approved to come to
canada
so that was the the first aspect of your
question on the charters and now i've
forgotten the second half
looking here one of my colleagues taking
notes for me do you mind just repeating
the second half of your question
[Music]
oh have we lost um i was just wondering
uh
hi
do you yeah i hear you
can you hear me
okay uh yeah so the second part of my
question was just uh uh with
the armed forces um military
with the canadians armed first uh
members that were sent in poland what
results uh that that uh achieved so far
um since they are on the field sure and
and sorry for the interruption to my
train of thought um so the canadian
armed forces personnel are going to play
a number of different roles um
one of the things that has been unique
in our response to this particular
initiative is the need to iterate and
continue to adjust as we hear about
issues on the ground that
may have have been unanticipated or
create an opportunity for us to improve
the
efficiency of our response
there are people who've fled ukraine as
you can imagine who have no idea about
what options they have in terms of where
they want to go
they also
don't necessarily benefit from
logistical support in terms of their
ability to move
from the uh the place where they've
exited ukraine to a canadian visa
application center
directing people as to where they want
to go and the information that they may
need to take part in the um
in the canadian program is one feature
that the canadian armed forces personnel
are going to be able to uh to take on
in addition we are now uh planning to
establish larger presences and
additional presences in warsaw and
berlin to more effectively process
people
we do still hear that some people
have for different reasons have
challenges accessing the application
process now that said our capacity
is
is in good shape we have the capacity to
process in excess of 19 000 biometrics
applications weekly uh at our locations
across europe and uh we but we do still
see that in warsaw in particular there's
large volumes of people that would
benefit from additional
people on the ground to help facilitate
access to the canadian program to the
extent that there are other humanitarian
or logistical supports they may provide
having a presence on the ground is
certainly only going to help things
operate more smoothly
thank you very much we will now return
to the floor i believe cbc has a
question
yeah hi mark carlsbc
the federal budget talks about the need
to address chronic labor shortages
but in canada there are skilled workers
in this country but they can't get
permanent residency
ircc hasn't held express entry draws for
canadian experience class
since last september for the skilled
workers program since 2020
can you give a concrete date as to when
draws which used to happen every two
weeks will happen next
um sure so it's really important that we
understand a little bit of context
i don't have a specific date for you
with all the details but i will be
sharing information on this very
specific point uh
very very soon uh in the next uh next
number of days um
just to under to appreciate this point
there's a unique uh strategy that the
government of canada adopted during the
pandemic to make sure that our economy
still benefited from the strength of our
immigration programs at a time when our
borders were closed to protect the
public from against the spread of coven
19 in our communities
the decision to continue to resettle
people who were here on a temporary
basis at a time to meet very ambitious
immigration targets
caused a number of people who were
applying through different programs
to to be on hold
in addition the processing capacity of
the
the federal government when it came to
immigration was impacted by the fact
that local offices all over the world
were actually closed down as a result of
potential exposure to covet 19. and in
many locations as you can appreciate the
ability to have staff work from home may
not have evolved as quickly
as it did here in canada and in other
certain parts of the world
there's a unique issue in particular
impacting
people who hold postgraduate work
permits
that are typically for a defined period
of time
and as a result of their potential
expiry of existing work permits they may
find themselves in a position if no
changes are made where they potentially
have to leave canada and may cease to be
eligible for certain programs based on
canadian experience there's another
related but unique issue on the federal
skilled worker straw
i'm completely aware of the issue we do
intend to introduce a solution to this
in a very short period of time and uh
and with respect i don't have a concrete
date for the actual uh
draws to resume uh but within a matter
of days we'll be sharing more
information once we have all of the
information available for the public who
may be impacted by this issue
any follow-up question
and uh
we are nearing the end of the event the
minister has to go somewhere around
for the day goes to the phone line
next i believe it's a canadian press if
i'm not mistaken
thank you have seen
the next question from the telephone
lines is laura osmond from the canadian
press
please go ahead your line is open
thanks so much
minister i'm wondering if you can
explain the benefit of flying ukrainians
to canada through sort of a corporate
partnership with air canada rather than
just giving funds directly to people
who've been approved to find their own
flights here
sure uh so one of the things that i
think's uh really important is you're
dealing with a a group of people who
are in really really challenging
personal life circumstances uh we want
to make sure that the resources that we
introduce as a federal government do
everything we can to facilitate people's
travel to canada and support them once
they get here
typically speaking we wouldn't be in the
business of
extending cash grants to people who are
thinking about coming to canada but
haven't made that decision who
ultimately
might make a decision to use those funds
for for another purpose we want to make
sure that we capitalize on the
opportunity to use the goodwill we're
seeing come from canada to support
people in in coming to canada as part of
this response
the government of canada to support
people who wish to remain overseas
isn't done in direct cash contributions
to individuals who find themselves
overseas is done through more
centrally organized humanitarian efforts
where you can actually have a much
bigger impact for every dollar that you
spend if you're looking for humanitarian
outcomes with respect to the
resettlement piece we want to make sure
the dollars that we invest on
resettlement
are promoting resettlement in canada
the extraordinary generosity that we've
seen from both air canada and the
shapiro foundation today
actually provides one of the most
effective and efficient ways for people
to possibly travel to canada
particularly given the unique facet of
this crisis that i described earlier
where people find themselves
not just in warsaw but also in vienna
bratislava bucharest berlin
you name a european country or city
there is a good chance that a
significant number of ukrainians have
arrived fairly recently
by extending this
generous goodwill to people who may find
themselves near an airport that has
access to the uh that the global
partners who will be eligible to
transport ukrainians
makes this
really an effective strategy to move
people
and certainly if you're looking for the
return on investment for each dollar
spent on resettlement i would be
hard-pressed to find a more effective or
efficient way to help as many people as
possible
do we have a follow-up question what's
going on
yeah maybe this question is for someone
with air canada but i'm wondering if
they're um
if eric is going to be organizing
dedicated flights for example for
ukrainians coming to canada or whether
um once these funds are available people
will be responsible for booking their
their own flights through the typical
channels
good afternoon
so if i understand correctly your
question just on the way it's gonna
it's gonna be implemented
the miles will be managed by uh miles
from migrant who's gonna inform the
ukrainian on how to book travel and and
and we're going to manage the the
booking process so i don't know if diane
is on the line if you can provide more
uh details about that
sure i'm happy too
oh god
barney please go ahead
oh sure i'm happy to uh so it's diane
padilla smiles for migrants and we are
ready to start accepting ukrainians who
are interested in traveling um at our
website myasthmamigrants.org and that
will be translated into ukrainian and
russian and we have protocols in place
to support the initiative and assist
ukrainians in need um we will be
accepting applications to uh for the
flight and we're prioritizing based on
you know first come first serve
and the timing is is we don't have exact
timing yet as it's still being finalized
but we anticipate
commencing the flights as soon as next
month
oh thank you everyone are you able to
say if those are dedicated flights for
ukrainians
or will they just be typical commercial
flights
i can
it's my understanding that we will
either would be a combination of charter
flights but also when we are booking
flights it's going to be on commercial
flights that are available um air canada
has um
well david i'll let you speak to the
question about um whether there would be
unique flights for ukrainians
so the announcement of today's really
focused on helping a ukrainian to come
in commercial scheduled flight as the
minister mentioned earlier in the press
conference currently canada is still
assessing
uh the need to organize charter flight
and
at this point we're going to have
discussion with the government when
those need will be established merci
so thank you everyone merci tourmonde uh
this ends the event unless the minister
wants no we're good all right have a
good day everyone merci benjaminate
thank you so much